first real job that I got paid for was
raking the sand traps at Oak Forest
Country Club in Longview Texas it's 77
tan tracks her screwed tees off like
6:45 in the morning especially if
they're gonna tee off in the back nine
I've got to have those traps raked by
7:30 work started about 3 a.m. and I'd
be out there the headlamp on raking
those chats I was late for whatever
reason you had to really buggy because
you've got a group coming and they're
catching up with me raking the traps and
they're the first ones on the course you
got the traps right but it was more fun
when the greenskeeper came to me and
said look we're having a problem with
some armadillos that are eating the
greens and as well as raking the traps
I'd like to hire you for the next two
weeks to come out from 10:00 p.m. to
3:30 a.m. when you start raking the
traps and I'm gonna give you a 22 and
you just spotlighted him on the green
that was the most fun part oh yeah I
always direct my head my my foot tracks
yeah well it's worse if you're playing
and you're in Atlanta and a traveler or
something didn't ring no I've got
respect for that the track raker
you